alright last time we started talking
about pseudo-random graphs and we
considered this theorem of chunk Graham
and Wilson which for dense graphs gave
several equivalent notions of quasi
randomness that means that face now you
do not appear to be all that we cover
them but they are actually you know you
can deduce one from the other there was
one condition at the very end which had
to do with eigenvalues and basically it
said that if your second-largest
eigenvalue in absolute value is small
then the graph is pseudo-random right so
that's something that I want to explore
further today to better understand the
relationship between eigenvalues of a
graph and the pseudo randomness
properties for much of pretty much all
today we're going to look at a special
class of graphs known as MD lamda graphs
this just means we have n vertices and
we're only going to consider mostly
other convenience t regular graphs so
this will make our life so much simpler
and the lambda stands for that if you
look at the adjacency matrix and if you
write down the eigenvalues of the
adjacency matrix then well what are
these eigenvalues the top one because
it's the regular is equal to d and the
lambda corresponds to the statement that
all the other eigenvalues are at most
lambda in absolute value so the top one
is equal to d all the other ones in
absolute value right so could be
basically the maximum of these two it's
bounded above by lambda
and at the end of last time we showed
this expander mixing lemma which in this
language says that if G is nd lambda
then one has the following discrepancy
type pseudo randomness property namely
that if you look at two vertex sets and
look at how many actual edges are
between them compared to what you expect
if this were a random graph of a similar
density then these two numbers are very
similar and the amount of error is
controlled by your lambda particular a
smaller lender gives you a more student
reading graph so the second part of
today's class I want to explore the
question of how small this lambda can be
so what's the optimal amount of pseudo
randomness but first I want to show you
some examples so so far we've been
talking about pseudo random graphs and
the only example really I've talked
about is that a random graph is
pseudo-random which is true random graph
is pseudo-random with high probability
but some of the spirit of pseudo
randomness is to come up with non random
examples come up with deterministic
constructions that give you pseudo
random properties so I want to begin
today with an example
a lot of the examples especially for
pseudorandomness come from this class of
graphs called Cayley graphs which are
built from a group we're going to
reserve the letter G for graphs I'm
gonna use gamma for group and I have a
subset s s of gamma and s a symmetric in
that if you invert the elements of s
they remain in s then we define the KD
graph given by the scoop and set s to be
the following graph where we the set of
vertices is just the set of hoop
elements and the edges are obtained by
taking a group element and multiplying
it by s to go to its neighbor so this is
a Cayley graph and no Cayley graphs are
you start with any group start with any
subset of the group you get a KD graph
and this is a very important
constructions of graphs they have lots
of nice properties and in particular an
example of a kini graph is a Paley graph
they're now related so a Paley graph is
a special case of a Cayley graph
obtained by considering the group the
sitter group Marty where P is prime 1
mod 4 and I'm looking at s being the set
of quadratic residue small people
yes actually non-zero quadratic residues
so elements of marpie that could be a
square so we will show in a second that
this penny graph has nice pseudo-random
properties by showing that it has an ND
lambda graph with lambda fairly small
compared to the degree just a squirts
historical note so raymond pay me pay me
graph named after so he actually so it
was from the earlier part of 20th
century so from 1907 to 1933 so he died
very young at the age of 26 and actually
died in an avalanche when he was skiing
by himself in Banff
so Banff is a national park in Alberta
in Canada and when I was in Banff
earlier this year for a math conference
so there's a also a math conference
center there so I had a chance to go
visit the Raymond baby's tone right so
there's a there's a grave yard there
where you can you can find his his home
it's very sad sure mathematical timespan
actually he managed to do a lot of
amazing mathematical finding a lot of
amazing mathematical discoveries and
there are many important concepts named
after him to you things like Paley
Wiener theorem Paley zigmund little wood
Paley all these important ideas in
analysis named after Paley and Paley
graph is also one of his contributions
so what working or what claim is that
this Paley graph has the desired
pseudo-random properties in that if you
look at its eigen values then the top
eigen values accept so except for the
top I can value Oh the other eigen
values are quite small so keep in mind
that the size of s is basically half of
the group so P minus 1
- so four especially larger values of P
these eigenvalues are quite small
compared to the degree okay
so the main way to show a Cayley graphs
like that have small eigenvalues is to
to just compute what the eigen values
are and this is actually not so hard to
do for candy crush so let me do this
explicitly so I will tell you very
explicitly a set of eigen vectors and
they are first eigen vector is just the
old ones vector the second eigenvector
is the vector coming from one Omega
Omega square Omega to the P minus one
where Omega is a primitive root of unity
the next one is one Omega square Omega 4
all the way to Omega P Omega to the 2
times P minus 1 and so on so I want to
half okay so I make this list so these
are my eigen vectors and let me check
that they are actually eigen vectors and
then we can also compute eigenvalues or
so the top eigenvector corresponds to a
one spectra in the d regular graph
that's always an eigen vector D and the
other ones we'll just do this
computation so instead of getting
confused with industries let me just
compute as an example
Jeff coordinate of the adjacency matrix
times V 2 so the jet coordinate so
whether it comes to so yes
the following some if I run over s then
Omega raise to j+ s s is symmetric so i
don't have to worry so much about plus
or minus so I say J plus s so if you
think about what this KT graph how it is
defined if you hit this vector with that
matrix that Jade coordinate is that some
dim but I can rewrite the sum by taking
out this common factor Omega 2 J and you
see that this is the Jade coordinate of
V 2 so and this is true for all J so
this number here is lambda 2 and more
generally lambda K is the following some
for K from 0 so from the K for being 1
through P when you plug in K equals to 1
you just get D and the others are sums
of these exponential sums now this is a
pretty straightforward computation and
in fact we're now using anything about
quadratic residues right this is a
generic fact about Kayla graphs of Zima
P so this is true for all KD graphs s
not necessarily for quadratic residues
and the basic reason is that here you
have the set of eigenvectors and they do
not depend on s ok so you might know
this concept from other places such as
circular matrices and this is true and
the simple computation
so now we have the values of lambda
explicitly I can now compute their sizes
I want to know how big this lambda is or
the first one when K equals to one is
exactly D degree which is P minus 1 over
2 but what about the other ones so for
the other ones we can do a computation
as follows so note that I can rewrite
lambda K by noting that if I take twice
it and plus 1 then I obtain the
following some ok so here I'm using that
s as a set of quadratic residues
consider there's some here every
quadratic residue gets counted twice
except for 0 which gets counted once and
now I would like to evaluate the size of
the Sun this exponential sum and this is
something that's no matter
cows um okay so basically a cow sum is
what happens when you have something
that's like a quadratic an exponential
some with a quadratic dependence in the
exponent and the trick here is to
consider the square of this sum so the
magnitude squared now if I expand the
square okay so the squaring is a common
feature of many of the things we do in
this course really simplifies your life
you do the square you expand the sum you
can reap ramírez one of the summons
do two steps at once and repro matera
Singh and I'm expanding but now you see
if I expand the exponent we find so
that's algebra and now you notice that
this sum here the sum over a is equal to
what when B is nonzero claimed that this
sum is zero I won't be is nonzero then
I'm summing over some permutations of
the roots of unity so here I'm assuming
that K is bigger than not you're sorry
parameterizing K a little bit case zero
then when B is not zero the sum over a
is zero and otherwise the equals to P so
the sum over here equals to P and
therefore lambda K I'm just up K change
zero so then lambda sub k plus 1 is
equal to plus minus P plus 1 over 2 for
all lambda not equal to zero
so really except for the top eigenvalue
which is the just a degree all the other
ones are you know one of these two
values and they're all quite small okay
so this is an explicit computation
showing you that this Paley graph is
indeed a pseudo-random graph it's an
example of a quasi random graph yes okay
the question is do we know what the sign
is so we actually so here I am not
telling you what the sign is
but you can look up actually people have
computed exactly what the sign should be
so this is something that you can find
in a number theory textbook like Ireland
Rosen any more questions there is a
concept here I just want to bring out
that you might recognize sums like this
right so this kind of sum that's a
Fourier coefficient so if you have some
Fourier transform this is exactly what
Fourier transforms look like and it is
indeed the case that in general if you
have an abelian group then the eigen
values and the spectral information of
the corresponding KT graph corresponds
to Fourier coefficients and this is a
connection that we'll see also later on
in the course when we consider additive
combinatorics and giving a Fourier
analytic proof of Rosse theorem and
therefore-- analysis will play a central
role but this is actually this analogy I
said Witten it is only for abelian
groups if you try to do the same for non
abelian groups you will get something
somewhat different so for non abelian
groups you do not have this nice notion
of Fourier analysis at least
versions that generalizes what's above
in a straightforward way but instead you
have something else which many of you've
seen before but under a different name
and that's representation theory which
in some sense is Fourier analysis except
instead of one-dimensional objects no
complex numbers who are looking at
higher dimensional representations I
just want to point out this connection I
will see more about later any questions
so let's talk more about Cayley graphs
all right so last time we mentioned
these notions of quasi randomness and I
said at the end of the class that many
of these equivalences between quasi
random graphs and they fail for sparse
graphs if your density if your edge
density is sub constant then the
equivalence is no longer hold but I what
about for cainy graphs in particular I
would like to consider two specific
notions that we discussed last time and
try to understand how they relate to
each other for Kayla drafts so for tense
KD graphs it's a special case of what we
did yesterday so I'm really interested
in sparse or Cayley graphs even bounded
degree even bounded degree
so that's much sparser than the regime
we were looking at last time and the the
main result I want to tell you is that
the disk condition is in a very strong
sense actually equivalent to the
eigenvalue condition for all Cayley
graphs
including non-abelian hailey grasp so
before telling you what the statement is
I first want to give an example showing
you that this equivalence is definitely
not true if you remove the assumption of
Kayla graphs for example if you okay so
example that this is false for non
Kayleigh because if you take let's say a
large so let's say D regular graph so
let's say a large random D regular graph
D here can be a constant or growing with
n by this pretty robust example and then
I add to it an extra destroying copiers
K sub D plus 1 that's much smaller in
terms of number of vertices the big
large random graph by virtue of being a
random graph has the discrepancy
property and because we're only adding
in a very small number of vertices it
does not destroy the discrepancy
property right so discrepancy property
if you're just adding a small number of
vertices it doesn't it doesn't change
much so this whole thing has discrepancy
however what about the eigenvalues claim
that the top two eigenvalues are in fact
both equal to D and that's because you
have two eigenvectors one which is the
old ones vector on this graph another
which is the old ones vector on that
graph these two days components each
give you a top eigenvector of D so you
get B twice in particular the second
eigenvalue is not small so the
implication from disk to I can value
really fails for non Cayley graphs for
general graphs
the implication the other direction is
actually okay the fact that eigenvalue
implies disk is actually the content of
the expander mixing lemma so this
follows by explained your mixing lemma
and that's because if you look at the
expander mixing them up for a king aguar
therefore for Cayley graph or if you
have the eigenvalue condition then
automatically you would find that these
two guys here are a most M so if lambda
is quite small compared to the degree
then you still have the desired type of
quasi randomness so I'll make the
statements more precise in a second
so the question is how can we certify
how can we show that in fact disk which
sits seemingly weaker property implies
the stronger property of eigen value for
KD graphs and what is a special ball
Cayley graphs I would allow you to do
this that the statement is generally
false for non Kayla grass okay so let me
define okay so let me first tell you the
results so this is a result due to David
:
myself two years ago so so many of you
may now have been to too many seminar
talks where you know there's this
convention in mathematics talks where
you don't write out your full name only
by the initial out of some kind of false
modesty but of course know we all love
talking about own results but somehow we
don't like to write our own name for
some reason okay so here's the theorem
so I start with a finite group
gamma and let me consider a subset s of
gamma that is symmetric and consider GP
Katie graph let me write n as the number
of vertices and D the size of s so this
is a D regular graph let me define the
following properties
the first property
I'll call disk with epsilon so I give
you an explicit parameter the number of
edges between x and y differs from the
number of edges that you would expect so
as in the expander mixing lemma so the
disk property is that this quantity is
small relative to the total number of
edges the second property which will
call I can value property like is that G
is a it's an MD lambda graph with lambda
at most epsilon D lambda is quite small
as a function of T the conclusion of the
theorem is that up to a small change of
parameters these two properties are
equivalent in particular eigen value
implies epsilon implies disk of epsilon
and disk of epsilon and this is a the
second one is the more interesting
direction it implies like while you lose
a little bit but at most a constant
factor I have eight Epsilon
okay any questions about the statement
so far so as I mentioned this is
completely false if you consider non
Cayley graphs and we also using expanded
mixing lemma using that implication up
there this direction follows one of the
main reasons I want to show you a proof
of this theorem is that it uses this
tool which i think is worth knowing and
this is an important inequality known as
scrolls and digs involve so many of you
probably know growth and ich asked this
famous French mathematician who
reinvented powder in algebraic geometry
and spend the rest of his life writing
homes and homes of texts that have yet
to be translated to English but he also
did some important foundational work in
functional analysis before he became an
algebraic geometry nerd and this is one
of the important results in in that area
that he so go from Dick's in equality
tells us that there exists some absolute
constant K such that for every matrix a
so real valued matrix
we have that the so we have that if you
okay so here's here's the idea let's
consider the supremum okay so let's
consider the following quantity this is
a bilinear form so this is a bilinear
form this is basically a bilinear form
if you hit by vector x and y from the
two sides and i'm interested in what is
the maximum value of this bilinear form
if you are allowed to take x and y to be
plus minus one valued real numbers okay
so this is an important quantity and
give you a matrix and they're basically
asking you know you get to assign a plus
or minus to each row and column and I
want you maximize this this number here
this is important quality that we'll see
actually much more in the next chapter
on graphing limits but for now just take
my word this is a very important
quantity and this is actually in
quantity that is very difficult to
evaluate if I give you know very large
matrix and ask you to compute this
number here there's no good algorithm
for it and it's believed that there's no
good algorithm for it on the other hand
there is a relaxation of this problem
which is the following
it's still some but now instead of
considering the bilinear form there
let's consider the excise and why is not
take the knock from real numbers but
take vectors so let's consider this some
where
taking similar-looking some accept that
excise and why ice come from a unit ball
in some vector space with an inner
product where P it's the unit ball in
some RM where here the dimension is
actually not so relevant dimension is
arbitrary if you like you know you can
make em and or 2n because you only have
that many vectors so this quantity here
just by very definition it's a
relaxation in the right hand side of
this this quantity here so it's at least
as large right so in particular if you
have whenever plus minus you can always
look at the same quantity with m equal
to 1 and you obtain this quantity here
but this quantity may be substantially
larger it's the x and y's have more room
to to put themselves in to maximize the
sum and growth and dekes inequality
tells us that the left hand side
actually cannot be too much larger than
the right hand side it exceeded by a
most a constant factor so in other words
the left hand side was just known as a
semi definite relaxation you are not
losing by more than a constant factor
compared to the original problem and
this is important in computer science
because the left hand side turns out to
be a semi definite program SDP which
does have efficient algorithms to
compute so you can give a constant
factor approximation to this difficult
to compute the important quantity by
using semi definite relaxation and
growth and inequality promises us that
it is a good relaxation
you may ask what is the value of K so I
said there exist some constant K so this
is actually a mystery so the current
proofs have been improved over time in
the growth and become self prove this
theorem but a constant has been improved
over time and currently the best known
result there is something along the
lines of K Guffey 1.78 works but the
optimal value which is known as cotton
the constant
so this is growth indeed constant
actually this is what I've written down
is what's called the real growth in the
economy can also write a version for
complex numbers and complex vectors and
that's the complex growth index constant
yes if your lower bound that is no yes
so it's no night it is strictly bigger
than one so there are some specific
numbers but I forget what they are you
can look it up okay
any more questions so well leave growth
and equality we'll use it as a black box
okay so if you wish to learn the proof
is I encourage you to do so it's there's
some quite nice proofs out there and
we'll use it to prove this theorem here
about quasi random Cayley graphs so
let's suppose disc hos so what we like
what do we like to show we want to show
that this eigenvalue condition holds and
we'll use the you know some min max
characterization of eigen values but
first some preliminaries suppose you
have vectors x and y which have plus
minus 1 coordinate values then by
letting okay so let's consider the
following vectors where i split up
x and y according to where they are
positive and where they're negative
so here these are such that X plus is
equal to so if I evaluate it on
coordinate G then is 1 if X of G is plus
1 and 0 otherwise its G sub minus this
one if X of G is minus 1 0 otherwise
so X splits into x + - x - + y splits
into y plus minus y - let's consider
matrix a where the G comma H entry of a
is the following quantity I have this
set s and I look at whether G inverse H
lies in s and that cake considered an
indicator of that which 1 or 0 and then
subtract the / n this value has mean 0
so this is a matrix and now if I
consider the bilinear form hit a from
left and right with x and y then the
bilinear form splits according to the
plus and minuses of the axis
and I claim that each one of these terms
is controlled because of disk so for
example the first term is if you expand
out what the sky are so here's an
indicator vector that's an indicator
vector and you know if you look at the
definition then this is precisely the
number of edges between X plus and y
plus minus D over N times the size of X
plus times the size of Y plus where X
plus is the set of group elements such
that X sub G is 1 and so on
all right so the punchline
up there is that this quantity so this
quantity is and most you know by
discrepancy epsilon the end so so this
sum here by triangle inequality is at
most for epsilon D
all right so so far we've reinterpreted
the discrepancy property and what we
really want to show is that this graph
here satisfies eigen value condition so
what does that actually mean
to satisfy the eigen value condition so
by the min/max characterization of eigen
values it follows that the maximum of
these two eigen values which is the
quantity that we would like to control
is equal to the following it is equal to
the supremum of the spy linear form when
x and y are vectors and this is simply
because a is the matrix it's not the
adjacency matrix it's not the adjacency
matrix a is the matrix obtained by
essentially taking the adjacency matrix
and subtracting that constant there and
subtracting that constant gets rid of
the top eigenvalue and what you remained
is whatever that's left and you want to
show that whatever you remain has small
spectral radius so we would like to show
that this quantity here is quite small
well let's do it give me a pair of
vectors x and y and let's set
the following quantities where I take a
twist of this X vector by rotating the
coordinates setting X super s sub G the
coordinate G to be X sub s G so so X is
a vector indexed by the group elements
and then rotating this indexing of the
group elements by s so that's what I
mean by superscript s and likewise y
superscript s is defined similarly okay
so I claim that these twists these
rotations do not change the norm of
these vectors and that should be pretty
clear because I'm simply relabeling the
coordinates in a uniform way and
likewise same for y
okay so I would like to show this
quantity up here is small so let's
consider two unit vectors and consider
this by linear form if I expand out this
by linear form it looks like that I'm
just writing it out
but now let me just throw in an extra
variable of summation
Oh what do yes essentially look at the
same sum but now I add in an extra s
so convince yourself that this is the
same some include simply reprimanding
there's some so this is the same sum but
now if you look at the definition of a
there's just cancellation so the 2's
cancel out so let's rewrite the sum 1
over n then G H s all group elements now
if I bring this summation of s now I
bring it inside and then you see that
what's inside is simply the inner
product between the two vectors X sub G
between the two vectors
ok so what's inside is simply the
product inner product between these two
so I may need to redefine
yeah so when you're looking at when
you're talking about non abelian groups
there's always the question of which
side should you multiply things by and
there okay well I need to change this
asked over here but anybody see it
should work yes good
YH thank you yeah I think
great
so I maybe I need to switch the
definition here playing any case some
version of this should be okay figure it
out later in the notes but no okay so so
you have this you have this here and if
you look at this quantity here it is the
kind of quantity that comes up in cloth
and digs inequality right so this is
basically the left-hand side of growth
index inequality what about the
right-hand side of growth index
inequality
well we already controlled that we
already controlled that because we said
whenever you have up there little accent
of the Y so the conclusion of this board
was that the conclusion of this sport
was that this by linear form is bounded
by a most for epsilon T for all X's Y
being plus minus 1 coordinate valued so
combining them by growth and eke we have
an upper bound which is quoting the
constant times for epsilon so for
epsilon T and
and therefore because the Courtney
constant is less than two we have a
pound of eight epsilon T and this shows
that this variational problem which
characterizes the largest eigenvalue in
absolute value is at most eight epsilon
D thereby implying the eigenvalue
property okay so the main takeaway from
this proof two things one there's growth
in the extend equality is a nice thing
to know right so it's a semi definite
relaxation that changes the problem
which is initially some more intractable
to a semi definite problem which is both
you know from a computer science point
of view algorithmically tractable but
also has nice mathematical properties
that for this application here there is
a nice trick in this proof where I'm
cement writing the coordinates using the
group symmetries and that allows me to
obtain this characterization showing
that eigen value condition and this
discrepancy condition are equivalent for
Cayley graphs let's take a quick wave
okay any questions so far
or so we're talking about n D lambda
graphs so T regular graphs and the next
question I would like to this address is
in and en der graaf how small can lambda
B so smaller lambda corresponds to more
pseudo random graph so how small can
this be and the right kind of setting
that I want you to think about is you
think of D as a constant so think of T
as a constant and n getting large so how
small and lambda P and it turns out
there is a limit to how small it can be
and it is known as the alone open a
bound which tells you that if you have a
fixed T and so G is an N vertex graph
with adjacency matrix eigenvalues lambda
1 to lambda n sort it in non increasing
order then the second largest eigen
value has to be at least basically two
root D minus one minus a small error
term at all n little one where the
little one goes to 0 as n goes to
infinity
so the aluminum panel bound tells you
that the lambda cannot be below this
quantity here and I want to explain what
there's a significance of this quantity
and you will see it in the proof and
this quantity is the best possible and
also say you know what do we know about
the existence of graphs which have
lambda too close to this number so this
is the optimal number you can put here
question okay question does they say how
negative lambda and can be so I'll
address that in a second but essentially
if you have a bipartite graph then
lambda N equals 2 minus lambda 1 okay
all questions so I want to show you a
proof and time permitting a couple
proofs of a Lobel panel bound and
they're all quite simple to execute but
the you know I think it's a good way to
understand how the spectral techniques
work okay so first as with all of the
proofs that we did concerning most of
them concerning eigenvalues were looking
at the quran fischer characterization
eigenvalues it suffices to show to
exhibit some vector Z
okay so a non zero vector such that Z is
orthogonal to the all ones vector and
this quotient is at least the claimed
bound right so by the Quran Fisher
characterization of the second
eigenvalue if you vary over all such d
that orthogonal to the unit vector then
the maximum value this quantity of
things is equal to lambda2
so to show that lambda 2 is large it
suffices to exhibit such Z so let me
construct such as G for you so let R be
a positive integer and let's pick an
arbitrary vertex V so we it's a vertex
in the graph and let V sub I denote
vertices distance exactly i from so in
particular V naught is equal to B and I
can draw you a picture so you have V
naught and then the neighbors of V
naught and each of them have more
neighbors
so I'm calling be not the set pick V not
and then pick the one V sub 2 and so on
okay so I'm going to define a vector
which I will eventually make into Z by
telling you what is the value of this
vector each of these vertices and we'll
do this by setting very explicitly set X
to be a vector with value X of U to be
WI where WI is t minus 1 raise to power
minus 2
whenever you lies in set big V sub I so
if US distance exactly I from V I said
it to this number so notice that they
decrease as you get further away from D
and I do this for all distances less
than okay so this is my X vector and I
said all the other back all the other
coordinates to be 0 the distance between
you and be leashed so like if you this
vector and I would like to compute that
quotient over there for this vector and
I claim that this quotient here
is at least the following quantity this
is a computation so let's just do it so
why is this true well if you compute the
norm of X so I'm just taking the sum of
the squares of these coordinates or that
comes from adding up these values I
neighborhood so I have W squared and if
I look at that quantity up there ok so
what is this a is the adjacency matrix
right here a is the adjacency matrix so
this quantity I can write it as sum over
all vertices U and I look at X of U and
now I some again over all neighbors u
Prime
it's that some day but this sum I have
some control over because it is okay so
also what is what's happening here I
claim it has at least the following
quantity consider where us so you could
be only nonzero if you lies in the R
minus 1 neighborhood so in that
neighborhood
I have mystified possible choices for
the vertex U for that choice this XW is
W sub R but what about its neighbors so
it could have neighbors in the same set
going left
but there's okay so there's one neighbor
going left and all the other neighbors
are maybe it's in the same cell maybe
it's in the next set but in any case I
have the following inequality there's
one neighbor in the same in the left if
you look at that picture just now and
then all the remaining neighbors have
except you
Prime's at least W sub I plus 1 because
these weights are decreasing so the
worst case so to speak is all the
neighbors point to the next set so I had
that inequality there there's an issue
because if you
go to the very last set if you go to the
very last set think about what happens
when I in that very last set I'm over
counting neighbors I no longer have
weights so I need to take them out so I
should subtract D minus 1 times ok so
this is the maximum possible weights um
I could have maximum possible over count
okay so each vertex here has t minus 1
neighbors at most all right so this
should be pretty straightforward if you
do their counting correctly but now
let's plug in what these weights are and
you'll find that this sum here this
quantity is equal to I mean so the key
point here is that this thing simplifies
very nicely if you consider what so what
ends up happening is that you get this
extra factor 2 root t minus 1 and then
the sum - okay so it's pretty
straightforward computation using the
specific weights that we have and one
more thing is that notice that this ok
so notice that the sizes of each
neighborhood
it cannot expand by more than a factor
of P minus 1 because you only have D
minus 1 outward edges going forward at
each step and as a result I can bound
this guy
what you find is that there's this whole
thing here is at least 2 x 3 t minus 1
the main term is the sum and this here
is less than each individual summit so I
can do a 1 minus 1 over 2 R ok putting
these two together you find the claim
all right
so I've exhibited this vector X which
has that quotient property but that's
not quite enough right because we need a
vector called Li up here that is
orthogonal to the old ones vector and
not you can do because if the number of
vertices is quite a bit larger compared
to the degree then I claim that there
exists U and V vectors vertices that are
at distance at least 2 R so if I let so
this is the size of this tree if you if
everything is within distance R distance
to are from a vertex then they all lie
on the street and if you come a number
of vertices in that tree it's what I
have there's some everything here so if
I consider these two vectors so be
so X be the vector obtained above which
is in some sense and I'm being somewhat
informal here centered at B and if I let
Y be the back sure but I century now at
the vector u then I claim that
essentially x and y are supported
disjoint vertex sets that have no edges
even between them so in particular this
in your product it's bilinear form in
the product but this by linear form is
equal to 0 since no edge between the
supports ok so now I have two vectors
that do not interact but both have this
nice property above and now I can take a
linear combination let me choose the
constant C that's a real constant such
that this Z equal to X minus CY
I can choose this constant so x and y
are both non-negative entries they're
both non zero so I can choose this
constant C so that it is the Z is
orthogonal to the old ones vector and
now I have this extra property I want
but what about the inner products these
two vectors x and y they do not interact
at all so the inner products split just
fine and the bilinear form splits just
fine so you have this inequality here as
desired and our notice that I can take R
going to infinity as n going to infinity
because T is fixed and goes to infinity
then R can go to infinity roughly a
logarithmic N and that proves the loan
Papa not bound X just to recap to prove
this bound we needed to exhibit by the
Quran Fisher some vector with a nice
this quotient such that this quotient is
large and we exhibit this quotient by
constructing the vector explicitly
around the vertex and finding two such
vertices that are far away from
constructing these two vectors taking
the appropriate linear combination so
that the final vector is orthogonal to
the unit vector to the old ones vector
and then showing that the corresponding
bilinear form has this large enough any
questions
I want to show you a different proof
which gives you a slightly worse result
but you know it's the proof is
conceptually nice so let me give you a
second proof slightly weakening and just
that what show so what show so the
earlier proof show that lambda2 is quite
large but next will show that the max of
lambda 2 and the lambda n is large ok so
not that the second largest eigenvalue
is large but the second largest I can no
absolute value so it's slightly weaker
but for all intents and purposes it's
the same spirit show this one here and
this is a nice illustration that what's
called a trace method sometimes also a
moment method here's the idea as we saw
in the proof relating the quasi
randomness of c4 and eigen values or C
force are most I can dollars are related
to counting closed walks in a graph so
we'll use that counting closed walks in
the graph and specifically the cue paved
moment of the spectrum is equal to the
trace the 2k power which counts the
number of closed walks of length exactly
2k
okay so to lower bound the left hand
side we want to lower bound the right
hand side so let's consider closed walks
starting at a fixed vertex so the number
of closed walks of length okay starting
at a fixed vertex B here when I do a
regular graph so here we are in ad
regular I claim you know whatever this
number is may be different from each V
it is at least the same quantity if I do
this walk in an infinite D regular tree
so infinity regular tree yes this is
infinite through regular tree
start with the vertex and then you
growth D regular so why is this true so
think about how you walk let me just
explain this is I think pretty easy once
you see things the right way to start
with the vertex V think about how you
walk and whatever way you can walk well
you can walk the same way on the
Infinity regular tree well I mean
whatever walk you can do on at infinity
regular tree if you label first vertex
first edge second edge if you do a
corresponding labeling on your words no
graph you can do that walk on your
original graph although the original
graph might have some additional walks
namely things that involve cycles that
are not available on your tree but
certainly every walk you can do every
closed walking you can do on the tree
you can do the same walk on your graph
so you can make this more formal right
so you can write down a batch action or
injection to make this more formal but
you know it should be fairly convincing
that this inequality is true but this is
just some number all right so this is a
number of 2k walks and the D regular
tree starting at a vertex and this
number has been well studied
I mean we don't need to know the precise
number just need to know some good lower
bound and here is one lower bound which
is that if there's at least a Catalan
number the cave Catalan number times D
minus 1 to the K where C sub K it's the
case Catalan number which is equal to ok
so k2 k2 is K divided by K plus 1 so
then we remind you what this is you know
one there has many combinatorial
interpretations and fun exercise to do
by directions between them but in
particular C 3 is the equal to 5 which
counts the number of ups and down walks
of length 6 that never dip below the
horizontal line where you start
so then this corresponds to going away
from the route versus coming back to the
route certainly have at least time
anyways and when you are moving away
from the route you have D minus one
choices which branch to go to good
given that the right-hand side is at
least then and the number of vertices
times the quantity above related to
Catalan numbers on the other hand the
left-hand side is at most here were
using a queue case even number is at
most D to the 2k plus okay so all the
other eigen values are a most lambda in
absolute value rearranging this
inequality we find that lambda to the 2k
is at least this number here
yes sir I'm changing a minus one to end
that and now what can we do we let n go
to infinity and K goes to infinity
slowly enough so if K goes to infinity
and n goes to so K goes to infinity with
N and but not too quickly but K is not a
rule of log n then we find that this
quantity here is essentially 2 to the K
2 to the 2k so and this guy here is the
tall one so lambda is at least 2 root D
minus 1 minus 1 so that proves
essentially the alone Poupon abound
although a small weakening because we
are this big
I can value my find might actually be
very negative instead of very positive
but that's ok before applications no
this is not such a big deal these are
two different proofs and I want you to
think about are they really the same
proof are they different proofs are they
related to each other ok so it's worth
thinking about they look very different
but how are they related to each other
and one final remark do you know you
already saw two different proofs as two
shows you this number and you see where
this number comes from and let me just
offer one final remark on where that
number really comes from and it really
comes from this infinitely regular tree
so it turns out that to root y -1
exactly is the spectral radius of the
infinite irregular tree and that is the
reason in some sense that this is the
correct number occurring along bopanna
bound this is you know if you've seen
things like algebraic topology or
topology this is universal cover for T
regular graphs some general remarks and
you already saw two different proofs so
the beginning of next time I want to
wrap this up and show you to explain
some what we know about are there graphs
from which this bound is tight and the
answer is yes and there's lots of major
open problems as well related to what
happens there and after that I would
like to start talking about graph limits
so that's the next chapter of this
course